oh man I can't wait for the new episode
of my hero the you a sports festival you
too can become a hero run meet later oh
man I can't wait for this new episode of
my hero academia internships I can't
wait for this new episode of my hero
academia stay is it just me or am I
starting to notice a pattern here
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that always sweats the small
stuff speaking of sweat you know what I
hate Tatsuki baka go with the
sandy-haired hyper-aggressive bully from
my hero academia I know I know I get it
he's learning to accept others and blah
blah blah blah blah but seriously dude
get over yourselves dammit it's one
thing to be stubborn and cocky but G's
dial it back once in a while even I have
to admit that despite his obnoxious
personality he has got himself one heck
of a fascinating superpower
well quirks in the hero academia
universe can range from godlike to
totally useless when Baku goes fun the
wheel he definitely landed closer to the
godly end of the scale if you don't know
the show let me tell ya he's got himself
the power to produce massive explosions
but the way that he activates that power
like Baku go himself is um less than
Pleasant you see baka goes quark isn't
just making things magically explode
he's no Yoshi cog Akira instead Baku
goes explosions are a byproduct of his
actual work which is that he sweats
nitroglycerin or to be more specific a
substance very similar to nitroglycerin
which he can detonate at will
essentially the sweater he gets the
bigger his explosions are and over the
course of the series we've seen Baku go
makes some lady darn big
earth-shattering kaboom even without his
special grenade gloves that store up his
uh fluids to create bigger blasts so of
course all this raises the obvious
question how much would baka go have to
sweat to create blasts as big and
powerful as he does welp you ought to
know by now that that's the exact sort
of insane question that I answer on this
channel so roll on some Old Spice and
make sure that you're wearing an
undershirt gland problem since today
we're literally working up a sweat to
prove how hot under the collar this
anime character gets and spoiler
he's producing more sweat daily than the
gaming room at your local anime
convention oh yeah it's that bad to
begin we're told that baka goes sweat is
basically identical to nitroglycerine
and since science knows a lot about how
much nitroglycerine expands when it
explodes I'm measuring a given explosion
from the anime we can work out pretty
easily exactly how sweaty baku go would
have to get to produce it now one thing
I'm not gonna do is look at what baku go
can do in his hero costume since those
grenade gauntlets of his are designed to
store his sweat over time thus making
their explosive power more based on how
long he's been wearing them as opposed
to how much he's actually sweating that
said the newest season of the anime has
given us a great benchmark in season 3
episode 3 were given a quark training
montage where each character is trying
to push their quirks to the limit in
order to expand their powers we're
expressly told that baku go is so not
only are these visually the largest
fireballs that he produces in the series
we also know that baku go is
intentionally pushing himself to his
limits here to unleash his full strength
both in terms of explosion size as well
as how fast he's making those explosions
happen at first i thought i could just
measure the blasts using baku go himself
as the measuring stick since he's right
there and we know that his cannon height
is exactly a hundred and seventy two
centimeters based on the character stat
cards that pop up between commercial
breaks however i wanted to be as precise
as possible which when it comes to baku
go is a bit of an issue he has that
super saiyan perm thing going on that
makes it hard to figure out how exactly
is Heights being measured and he almost
never stands up straight
lucky for us though Baku is not the only
measuring stick that we have at our
disposal here he's standing next to an
oil drum the exact same kind of oil drum
that his fellow classmate Todoroki is
using for his training and with his good
posture and flat haircut this icy hot
honor student makes for a much better
measuring stick we know that from healed
ahead Todoroki stands at 176 centimeters
tall that means using his height in this
mug a profile picture as a baseline we
can determine his pupillary distance or
the distance between the Centers of the
pupils of his eyes a measure
that's often taken by optometrists
during AI appointments on average male
pupillary distances are between five
point three centimeters and seven point
seven centimeters and Todoroki z--
pupils are exactly 7.62 centimeters
apart so it falls right in that range
this measurement can then be translated
over to the training montage to measure
the barrel from side to side in this
shot which gives us a barrel diameter of
seventy nine point eight eight
centimeters finally we can apply those
barrel measurements to the one standing
next to baku go to measure the diameter
of the fireball and here's where we run
into one other snag you see we're never
actually shown the full scale of the
fireball that baku go creates despite it
being a distance shot that we can
clearly tell goes above the treeline so
we're just gonna have to settle for
measuring the part of the fireball that
we can actually see in this flat on shot
but trust me even that is more than
enough if we cut a chunk off the
fireball starting at the widest point
before it goes past the edge of the
screen we get a dome that's two thousand
five hundred forty five centimeters
across by seven hundred and sixteen
centimeters tall plugging those numbers
into this formula which measures the
volumes of spherical caps gives us a
total volume of two thousand four
hundred twenty-eight point two cubic
meters or two million four hundred
twenty-eight thousand two hundred and
seven litres of exploding gas that
certainly sounds like a lot but to truly
understand what that means let's dig a
little deeper doing a little research we
know that when it explodes nitroglycerin
expands to a little over twelve hundred
times the volume of its original liquid
form so all we have to do is divide the
volume of the explosion by twelve
hundred to see just how much sweat baku
go would need to produce it leaving us
with a final grand total of a whopping
two thousand twenty three and a half
liters of sweat to put that in
perspective an average human produces
between point eight and 1.4 liters of
sweat during an hour of exercise or for
a fair point of comparison since baku
goes using hot water to open up a sweat
glands an average person produces just
one litre of sweat after 15 minutes in a
steam room baku go is sweating at least
two thousand times that amount
the five seconds between explosions in
this scene and remember that's just part
of the fireball the whole thing is three
to four times the size of what we can
actually measure which means that Baku
Co is probably producing closer to six
thousand liters of sweat in five seconds
from just the palms of his hands that's
about a hundred and fifty times the
total volume of liquid contained in the
average human body and if a real person
were truly sweating that much liquid
they shrivel up and die like a prune in
a fraction of a second but let's just
ignore that problem for a moment and
assume that baku goes quark somehow
compensates for this rapid fluid loss by
other means the same way it prevents his
explosions from blowing his hands off I
mean after all this is a universe where
a guy's whole body can be made out of
teleporting mist or a guy's face can be
made out of flame or a guy can have
teeth that turn into magically long
blades so who's to say what is and isn't
possible with these darn quirks assuming
that he wouldn't die from it in terms of
liters per second baku go is sweating
over a million times faster than the
average human being that's thinking for
a minute he is sweating a million times
faster than you if you were to stand
with that barrel in an Olympic swimming
pool he would be able to fill the entire
thing with his sweat in 34 minutes and
43 seconds every 30 minutes he's
sweating the amount of an Olympic
swimming pool Oh gross sweating is the
act of a healthy body of course
kugo isn't gonna spend all day in sauna
conditions but even at regular
temperatures he'd be sweating buckets on
a daily basis literally sweating buckets
on an average day a regular person will
produced between 500 and 700 milliliters
of sweat and a million times that rate
baku go would be sweating between five
and seven hundred thousand liters every
single day which let's be honest would
probably mean he'd need to drink a
little bit more than eight glasses of
water per day to stay hydrated and it
would definitely mean that i wouldn't
want to sit anywhere near him in class
or on a bus clearly baku is going in the
completely wrong direction when he chose
his hero named king explosion murder I'm
gonna say that one's a little too
violent
forget all that with palms sweaty as
yours buddy you're better off calling
yourself The Swamp Thing
hey that's just a theory a film theory
and cuts
[Music]